i got big feet so i can't wear every
jordan that's out there because
i'll be looking like timbuktu
hey what's up y'all it's the icy girl
sweetie and this is
my life and sneakers
these are my first ones that i want to
share with you guys
my luckiest pair of shoes i have my uggs
and the reason why i say these are the
luckiest because every time
i'm going to set for a photo shoot for a
music video
or for anything that i'm working in i
arrive comfy and fly
and these are fly and comfy growing up i
had one pair of uggs
because they were expensive at least to
me
and i remember being pissed off because
i didn't put the protection
over the uggs and it had
rained on one cold winter day
and my uggs got messed up like real ugg
owners know that when the
when the water hits the ugg it creates
this this
weird it it basically distorts the
material and i was very upset
but i still wear my uggs because they
keep my feet so warm and comfy
every time i pull up to the to the shoot
with some
uggs on it's a bomb ass shoot so thank
you
mwah these are my luckiest pairs of
shoes
so these are my most underrated
pair of sneakers growing up you know the
pack
i had in my space they were blowing up
through the functions
and they had a song called vans you know
got my vans on but they look like
sneakers
it just was like a crazy wave
of sensation through the bay area and i
loved it
because i could afford these vans and to
this day i still wear
my vans and when i wear them people are
kind of like looking at me crazy
which is why i feel like they're the
most underrated pair of shoe that i have
when i'm wearing i'm definitely laid
back sweetie
i'm like chilling i'm cool i'm running
errands i might pull up to the mall
to go shop because they're cool and
they go with everything and when i'm
like in them they're just super comfy so
these are definitely my most underrated
pair of shoes
all right y'all so my most flashiest
shoes are
my louboutins
these are the spikes michelle can you
please just bring them up to the clam
camera really quick and just like yes
and just move it around just just the
other way just let it sparkle
just girl just let it sparkle okay
all right so like these are like my
studio shoes and every time i walk into
the building like people are like amazed
they're like oh my gosh i'm blinded so i
know
these are my most flashiest shoes and
these are
expensive as well these are about 3 500
you know including tax so i definitely
tried to take good care of these i
believe these are swavoski
spikes so when i wear these i'm normally
naked
because i feel like they're just a
statement piece
so
i'm just playing y'all no but i went
into the studio
i put these to the studio i feel like
they get the
creative juices flowing and
whoever's in the building they're amazed
by my shoes
for my rarest shoes i have my melody
times
jordan it's super cute i remember
growing up
and jordans were super hard to get so
the fact that
melody sent me these herself it just
means everything it got the little
cherries right here
super cute black red and they're hella
exclusive
and i definitely couldn't afford
jordan's growing up i remember okay i
have a story
i had the dub zeroes and i remember
they're my only pair of jordans and i
was super excited about them
and i have to catch my busting time so
i'm literally
running out of the last period and i'm
running through the grass
i forgot that it rained that day and i
got mud
all over my dub zeros i literally i
cried and i went home and i washed them
off with a wet rag
but my dub zeros the the black ones with
the gold accents on them
they were done for but guess what i
still wore them to school
my absolute pair of jordans are the
jordan ones
because i got big feet so i can't wear
every jordan that's out there because
i'll be looking like timbuktu
i'm just so grateful that she sent these
to me herself
my sexiest pair of shoes are definitely
my thigh
high louboutins i know that's right girl
these are just so sexy i just need to
put them in rotation really quick
these are definitely you know picking
the kids up from school
going to the grocery store these are
going to the gas station
cause it's all about the vibe y'all it's
all about the vibe
when i first found these it just so
happened that i was just like shopping
i was shopping i think in outlander and
they had just came out and i was like oh
my gosh these shoes are so expensive but
i have to get them
and they were definitely worth every
penny
dime nickel whatever you want to call it
because
it's just too good y'all if you put
these on
it just turns you into a bad [ __ ] there
ain't no big event that you pair with
you know
the special thigh highs you wear them
wherever you want to wear them
so these are definitely my sexiest pair
of shoes
whenever i go out i feel like a bad one
so these are my most sentimental because
my daddy used to wear these shoes
growing up
um his nickname is blue so
you already know what time it is and
they're just super comfy
and i love them because they remind me
of my dad he still has his shoes
i call him his you know his big papa
shoes that's what i call him big papa
and he um wears him around the house he
don't really wear him out like that
though
so normally when he's just you know
cooking or cleaning he's wearing these
type of shoes
slippers and slides are hella essential
for the collection because
you know they're just easy to put on and
off i love me a shoe that i can just
you know get up and go and they're just
easy to work with
so i love my slippers and my slides
because i'm able to just you know run in
and at the house with them on
all right y'all y'all have officially
tapped into a piece
of my shoe collection i got my uggs i
got my two christian louboutins
i got my jordans thai melody asani
i got my vans and i got my swap meet
shoes
i mean real ones know about these shoes
but anyways this
is just a tip of the iceberg hopefully
i'll be back to share more
so make sure you stay tuned